you really try and get Rob Zombie
director/screenwriter
well that's all you want to do it
[Laughter]
together
I want one I want a gusher I like that
guy sure a lot of gestures really yeah
you want through by foot yeah I'll do
that so what you can't even Road by the
fuzz throw that good I know right were
you later sup bro I can tell if you want
drew breezy dude
drool breeze bro breezy like a
transgender ninja you look like Drew
Brees bro you threw that [__] like
you've been in a wheelchair duh no
[__] in wheelchair that's all he can
do is throw they can't kick though
don't ask them a [__] kick fine idiot
what's up doggy oh not much man getting
through these quarantine times yeah
little security thought at the front
make sure you have your mask on yeah
yeah was he giving you our time no cuz I
kind of put it on and they looked in I
pulled it down hoping to argue with him
well yeah you know but he was like
whatever dude I get paid seven dollars
now it's just he was racial to me I felt
like cuz he thought it was black because
of this man he's like what are you boys
doing around he's i watch your time
doing around here boy you're like dude I
work and I was like dude anyway oh [__]
my back like oh man that was a quickie
woman up [__] you think I can just
dunk all of a sudden you just run away
off fast for 340 you want me to
freestyle free Jesus man yeah that's
been chilling man not too much really
I hear you dawg almost job my
rattlesnake today you almost ran right
over it I posted that [__] you should
have ran over it um I don't know this
thing was thick
let me see that thing that's not that
big he's not small things gorgeous I've
seen way bigger than that that's what
she said I'm breathing pretty hard now
it was a nice little break to be honest
I don't take many breaks yeah I see them
all the time all the time
I think slow huh it looks pregnant he
didn't give a [__] dude
well it's probably a a woman and B it's
pregnant he stopped stared at me on the
camera she would be pregnant I don't
know if the pregnant man everyone says
about every thick snake oh it's pregnant
oh really oh that thing oh really
Crocodile Hunter huh oh really crocodile
I grew up in Louisiana crocodile tears
you don't know [__] snakes that's a
long raccoon where I'm from dude they're
everywhere
that's a charnel raccoon that dinner for
Obama for the Von's that's nothing and
that's a big snake skin boots for the
Vaughan yeah hey here's my thing if I
get bit by that about about 40 minutes
from home would I die you think I'm too
big to die from a rattlesnake bite right
I don't think you want to go home you
want a doctor
dude I can't get to a doctor on my bite
from there I'm in the middle but if you
tried hard I'm gonna say if you say you
can't yeah you're never gonna do it yeah
you're right
would you watch Jocko this morning huh
that drink you start spitting out
[__] motivational talk I'm just
telling you what's going on bro I've
been up since 4:30
doing what lift and bro oh really yeah
lifting curling what are you lifting huh
pills into your health what kind of what
bro you look like a straight-up seaman
hit man on the Navy battleship dude you
dress like a dude you look at you with
nice chain you look like you give back
rubs at a rap battle sick flow bro this
is vintage steel you idiot ever Malibu's
Most Wanted would you change from
Spencer's obviously shop dispensers dude
I get scared he got his fence hi kids
easy on the rectum already stuff yeah he
looks like it's here yaar that hides
stuff in the store so you can buy it
later
oh man hope don't get all these uh wins
stefani dolls that's the last large
laugh that this Rugrats T these swing
keys are hot in the street I'm just
gonna put one under the shoe back oh hey
[Laughter]
bro you look like a guy who his CP part
of somebody's [__] on a mouse ponder
okay gang bang everybody hi J alright
bull huh GG up baby who needs a Red Bull
Carl another Red Bull for you you look
pretty just don't really get out there
buddy a lot of work but yeah great
technique with the motorbikes get out of
you make grilled cheese for [__] Andy
Dick Whitey dress like he make you dress
like you're wearing a woman's shirt
first of all you show your that must
have like a blouse this is a banana hey
did you come in on a skateboard
I might've I look nice I think you do
look nice dude what are you talking
about your line you just sound like nice
dude you just said all the other stuff
you don't think I heard it I apologize
I don't even know how time works you
idiot I was just here with you freak we
got a video right here that came in from
somebody let's see what's going on
this is our first King under sting it
okay
I love them oh yeah
a goat love I well this is Brad exotic
this shit's dope a goat love ice
[Laughter]
beautiful goats you ever jumped on ice
bath before yeah man I love them dude
I'll go under me too I love them
you won't go all the way I'll go all the
way down there you I thrive in the cold
no I love it dude if you thrived in the
cold you would have stayed in Denver
dude no dude I thrive in the cold not
about the tude bro get your facts right
I told you this both of them in the test
same thing you hold you the Senate tax
so now I'm dude well at high altitude
[Laughter]
now you know if I can bring your dress
like a medic in World War men all this
[__] busboy at the [__] Boston Red
Sox rap like God somebody get this guy a
real job those are my pants he look like
the oldest manager dressed like that and
you know man
yeah bro its policy policy bro
yeah dude back off these Bart Simpson
shirts I got over here okay dude I love
spencer's man I know you didn't see how
they stay hoping though I never saw
anybody buy anything ever hmm no one
ever bought anything all right like you
could get some lava lamps and that's
about it
you get beavis and butthead statues some
Selena shirts mm-hmm all right Peter a
lot of posters yeah you get good posters
in there are kids still into posters I
am oh well I'm not a kid just admitted
that you [__] have some issues with
growing up pose look dude
what posters did did you have grown-up
care beget posters um I used to have a
poster of Britney Spears and a poster of
Paul Walker and fast and furious [__]
love Paul Walker also Walker is the love
of my life
well I used to be right yes did you go
to any memorials form or anything like
that like what was it like for you I did
not go to any memorials but I did loiter
outside of a Tapioca express when I
found out that he died and there's a
bunch of like Asian dudes with like
modded cars so is basically my version
died in a Porsche died in a Porsche GT
Porsche GT a thing is the Widowmaker it
is oh the car he was driving was Abby
sings a piece of [__] and but I think
his buddy was driving got a [__]
they'll be like me letting you drive my
car and then I died you've got a bit
well I'll just tell you right now that
that's how it would go down no I know if
you ever let me drive that bastard son
be the end of your life look at that
[__] a great car great car dude wise
yeah
well no you can't still get him nah
killed him dude I know his buddy killed
him his buddy killed him huh his buddy
killed the garden kill him
the buddy did both of them did yeah and
that was God Walker what I like me
definitely I think more than you no I
don't think so I don't think so cuz I
know cars and then you know you gotta
have like a gay vibe I feel like you
always try to massage his feet
yeah bro dude we have a plus sign on
your head dude okay nothin an ass on
yours yeah dude you're Lana
yo huh yeah but the hennas yeah and this
is a [__] signature ad dude there's a
nice hat it is a nice hat I kind of like
it thank you very much oh you like the
banana it's a little plus sign hat hey
me add me buddy
[Laughter]
the oh if you take two straight man and
put you between them bro that's gay
right there's gay man oh oh yeah if you
were in an M plus on bro why did you why
did you go into an ice bath honey back
to this why did you get an ice pack to
recover man from to recover from some of
a lot of strong Fitness I've been doing
a lot of adult activity intense training
what else
nice ice bath did you read comic books
better line up the ice bath dude I did a
lot of high-pressure training you freak
you still with that trainer's just blown
out you know Nicki Minaj trainer don't
delay that lady off yeah she wanted me
to wear a thong and get a My Little Pony
tattoo
she's trying to turn you into Instagram
thought really a business decision
I said I'm shutting this down tell you
right now bro what got my athletic
greens not feeling great
oh damn really take it everyday usually
feel phenomenal but not today man you
got to get it in your system
I know what happened just forgot oh man
I'm gonna text you tomorrow and remind
you man because I've been taking them
right out of the morning I get up I get
a glass of water from the kitchen water
machine water faucet sure next thing you
know I'll put in my pack I put in my
pack of athletic greens you feel great
oh I feel like The Incredible Hulk bro
dude the one thing health experts
dieticians athletes top performers agree
on that the perfect diet doesn't exist
Theo
even with a bounce healthy diet can be
tough to cover your nutritional bases oh
I can't do it through food alone that's
why I flooded Green said hold the food
check this out I thought greens
alternate daily all in one a string dude
yeah 75 proven vitamins minerals Whole
Foods sourced ingredients all I know
what's in there man they got probiotics
prebiotics
digestive enzymes adaptogen superfood
more giving you one-stop shop to help
get your body's nutritional level where
you need it to be man I'm just wondering
why you're seeming all just kind of like
my luggage I know dude I know man I
thought greens doesn't compromise
is on ingredients in sourcing it's
gluten-free dairy-free keto free it's
just it ain't all free but it's pretty
much free alright keto bruh yeah y'all
rappers brother in prison wrong all of
them shot the little greens whether
you're taking steps towards healthier
lifestyle or you're an athlete pushing
for better performance athletic greens
takes the guesswork out of everyday good
health why not just try it jump on over
and you'll be able to jump further if
you're on these things to athletic
greens calm /ka TS and claim our special
offer today 20 free travel packs value
and we'll $79 with your first purchase
that's athletic greens calm /k 80s oh
man oh you want to see my ID look man if
I had an irrelevant oh I had an erection
I'd show it to you I would too but I
don't have one me neither
he's have he's having trouble trouble
waking up dude and you know this a
common issue 40% of men by the age of 40
struggle with their dicks not be able to
jump up oh I see that's why you're
always filming those snakes on your ride
yeah you know they're moving you got to
get it where you can get it man you know
where you fit it yep it's a common issue
40% of men by age 4-0 struggle from not
being able to get and maintain erection
yeah man check out hims he could
discover the tiny pill worth a big
celebration yep [__] hems , one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for the bros take care yourself
hims
connects you with real licensed doctors
and fda-approved pharmaceutical products
to treat edy and that's it and that's
erectile dysfunction just like Big Ed
from that show when it won't sprout you
got that big yet yet that Ed you go
don't be at anymore dude try him today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to four hymns calm /ka ts5 that's fo
r hims calm slash cats five four hymns
calm slash cats five praise god help
your pecker get that neck baby see
website for full details and safety
information
remember that's for hams calm slash tats
five damn I can't believe that that Paul
that Paul Walker Paul Walker would
definitely choose me though I think
Brendan I don't know
think about it man think about it he was
in the gym you're saying it's I'm not
thinking of using the jiu-jitsu think
about it he's a purple in jiu-jitsu but
here's what thinking about it is man
here's the thing I know you're friends
with Dustin Poirier so I think you know
jujitsu but Paul Walker actually did you
Jitsu and he's into Porsha's name one
thing you have in common with Paul
Walker broke he got putting her freaking
forever naked choke by a [__] Porsche
okay I don't think he did that good the
Porsche never let him tap who made a
seatbelt Brice Mitchell because somebody
[__] put that do it into a serious
all right
understand if that's who can't make his
way out of a seatbelt and that's that
bro all right P but I'm just saying he
would like me better than he would like
you dude all right what about Paul wall
M me Paul fan course your buddy now does
he send his team send me a grill yeah
they did
oh you know all wall grill never seen
you wear it dude really say it I can't
wear that because I'm not riff raff
that's not friendship then where I'm
problem okay
so it seems you grill you should win you
got a rocket next time I'll wear dude I
thought you get I'll work for you yeah
I'll wear my gold I got a gold chain
it's not really it's not the same well
it's not as real steel so I think you're
good verified silver you freak you guys
don't know anything about that - Thank
You brothers right that's it I see bro
oh you upper [__] foot long around my
neck
somebody almost skated by on somebody
cut their finger with one of them skates
it was ice-skating on the net on this I
wonder what I'll put on it some [__]
ice I see you need me burn so Paul
Walker would be my friend Paul wall
would be my friend Paul from the Bible
Dawg I'll keep Paul and dog up all till
we fall brother scope all from the Bible
here's a guy right here dude here's my
boy Carl Lentz no this is also the guy
from don't [__] with cats
like I didn't I didn't II know you
didn't I
he didn't DQ my suicide no you went to
prison he should have I think his I
forget how dense oh my how do you have
ideas and I'm like wow he has them this
Frozone last week yeah damn that's
amazing Wow
is he dead though Nick the people's
pastor right there dog
I think he looks like him that you win
this round he wishes he looked like the
Lord's [__] hey you think I'll find
out what she looks like the Lord's [__]
boy I like that guy I do like him the
Lord's bad boy oh please please get me
in heaven yeah bro you got it you should
have read that down before you said it
because I really really want to be there
no I do ball throw Paul out there dog
Paul wall I got Paul what you're gonna
be my friend Paul wall Paul George would
be my friend Paul Bunyan son no dog
alright let's hear what this guy's to
say then here's somebody right here you
called this is you get you got this guy
we do it's not suji don't let me forget
yeah yeah japanese'
my name is James I come from Scotland
afraid of these baby my king or stinger
is quite simple the Scottish accent king
or stinger Gang Gang buzz buzz
or glass regions would see okay gang
buzz-buzz peace and love
brothers something's going on there that
I don't know I know what's going on
that's easy murder murder of cats this
guy owns a couple extra knives if you
know what I'm saying
right oh oh you like this knife pocket
on my pants I'm like I don't think
you're supposed to put a knife in that
pocket it's just a regular pot yeah you
can put a knife in any pocket uh thank
you for the message from Scotland dude
you know Scott Lenore is brynan or as I
like to call it Brendan's Brea cancer
going back to the motherland dude
shoutout to the white motherland
Scotland I want to say what is he asking
about is he no just his accident in
general Scottish at Scotland Braveheart
lightly yeah that's right brave William
Wallace yeah Colin is very I love you
always have I love you I love you come
on do it huh that's a little Schwartz in
a right okay
they don't have any Swartz and naggers
in Scotland dude okay first of all
that's a fact that's a fact
yeah never seen a black guy in Scotland
black guy wouldn't mean I'm talking like
the Austrians Austrians Austrian dude
I'm just saying I've never seen a black
guy in Scotland have you have you been
there yeah they have a couple blank
Scots I don't think so like Scottish man
I'm sure there's one but you don't see a
lot of them you don't see a lot dude but
you could you be a black Scot man I feel
like oh I will for sure will I am he
[__] axe like years bro
he shouldn't be faking it so much
there's a guy right there what about
that shirtless guy up there Brendan's a
little buddy right
this little chocolate sugar sickle
gobbling [__] in your face
check out that trouser snake dude got
the bagpipes I'm Brad
it's crazy Brendan Brendan biked up on
this he would just just stop and film
the guy's [__] for about 13 seconds I'm
sure yeah look at this thing I think
it's pregnant Scotland Down Under do any
sense
I like Scottish accents I like Scottish
accents too because you can get out like
especially if you come to like if you
come to another country to go to another
country you can get out of anything
nobody knows you're talking about
you don't know what you're talking about
it's a win-win you know and they
basically just took the Irish accent and
they're like we don't want to be Irish
we need to make it we need our own thing
yeah and it's like hey I'm gonna talk
Irish woman somebody punch me in the
face while I'm talking yeah yeah so you
have a guy who's just like oh he's just
like talking and Scottish you know and
you do it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go King it man I came the [__]
out of it I think chicks dig the accent
too right cat yeah do you why I like
accents in general yeah mmm
most chicks dig an accent Sean Connery
we see Scottish he's Scottish I'll tell
you who else is Scottish dude um the
late great Gerry Gerard Butler right
from 300 yep I'll also tell you another
Scotsman um Jonathan Davis from corn he
plays the bagpipes he does yeah okay is
he Scottish I don't know he plays the
bass move yeah yeah it's pretty Scottish
I would say master from awesome powers
is he really okay how do you know it he
says it what are you some Saudis yep I'm
Scotty Oh Oh get in my bed
my belly me belly my belly Gerard Butler
I want to also tell you who the famous
late-night talk-show host Craig Ferguson
is a Scot ah he might be the best one I
like that guy
I'm gonna go Jerry Butler dude really
yeah 300 300 yeah who else is out there
who's another famous Scot dude shutout
Scotland yet they don't even have
usually they have like an arrow and you
can scroll through they don't even have
that option they just have these six
people
that's amazing online let me take group
there there should be proud of that
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I don't see a
lot of bagpipes these days if you go to
a corn concert you'll see
yeah get out more yeah yeah quarantine
that's what they should call the next
toy yeah all right 14 great idea I love
corn all right I'll do this let's put
this up on the thing hanger sing it for
the audience corn the band or corn hey
Oh me and or cor head er is backwards
you know yeah corn the banner corn the
meal or the Quran put it up yeah
dude three on Twitter or the Quran and
then do just the two on Instagram oh
yeah okay here's this guy like a nice
fresh corn don't you give my teeth oh I
like or man I like corn a sweet corn D
do you remember did you ever have when
you're growing up corn and milk
sorry timeout creamed [__]
I love Christmas aside with a steak you
creamed corn is just corn and milk right
not really
yeah I think your mouth ko is captain
crunch crunch tastes like [__] but it's
still pretty good
yeah yeah that homemade dinner time
captain this is our last king of saying
it before we get to whatever like warts
it's got work to the Comedy Store
doesn't sing this is ralph from central
california or standard from CA means and
mean games so I got some examples I got
cat probably after receiving the hundred
DP big pic gang got chin mask off Knicks
grandma right I got Derek probably one
can't escape this guy thought Derek
Derek Derek got into skateboarding
[Laughter]
taking this thing I got Derek for
college we got Theo brag about the time
he canceled all those shows and Brea
Brandon waiting for chins on to text
them back all ready to go and then of
course me Oh every time I see my body
during this quarantine every time ceases
why does not embody the gang gang
buzz-buzz y'all stay safe love the show
keep it up god great submission Wow
quality submitted your name Ralph huh
yeah and you don't hear that name much
anymore and also to send him for
vomiting remember it used to be yeah I
got rally guy Ralph Ralphie yes may
Ralph to my book sacks all right dude
least have a guy and he drowned from
people's uh backpacks and stuff during
recess that was his big thing he'd eat
lunch and
go vomit right fine I get a lot of
chicks right huh right now all that
chicks were digging that Mommy were like
fine I think we were like fourth grade
or something five grace yeah so yeah
probably not get any chicken but also
nobody you were getting chicks but you
just had to stand around and just hold
their head nurse you right I'd rather
vomit in people's bags dude you right
I'm not gonna just stare at something
girl
we got really early results but who
would be better friends with paw wash
Brendan in the lead I don't I don't
think I can a beach whaling yourself I
think yeah dude I've surfed twice as
well okay Brendan that doesn't even that
I'm a surfer all right just because if
you if you want if you think you're like
Paul Walker then died in a car accident
well good chance I'm just saying dude
I'll be it y'all so I love you I don't
want you to but what if it happens you
know but I'm just saying if you want to
have the clown until I feel let me go go
on a Porsche GT who know who'd be better
friends with Paul Wall CEO by a
landslide
Jane light up like a lamp when I'm back
in the camp when they figure out where I
work I got 80 folks poking now at the
club I'm showing it now I'm gonna play a
ain't no doubt hos one no word on bail
biggest diamonds I'll fill my mouth
prison my only not white rapper let's
get a new picture of Paul wall up man
hey what was his main hit Paul Walt
ugly no that was Bubba Sparxxx my bed
grills
I know but me see you grill yes yet one
something off ride slow rap and had
kanye west's on it remember I was like
oh yeah right slow homie that
ohmy God that's a faux wall release this
thing will break him off
god that's a scenario millionaire what
did he have Paul wall baby they don't
know on the People's Champ
People's Champ yeah poses main hit
though if you just play that from the
next I can [__] get my boy Paul
Holmes right there break them off I'm
throw know what fit in sideways sitting
sideways
go to send sideways Nick look at Paul my
beautiful young fell out of Texas wasn't
he was Houston
beautiful young man sitting sideways
boys in the day he's only four Paul was
five three men oh really
hey wait how's the sodium 1.5 million
like us Molly a little Paul a little
Paulie Doug he makes me want to drink
scissor oh yeah scissor little sprite Oh
codeine that little Wayne drip so cool
he was ice cold huh whose don't man
let's shut this down this is pretty bad
it's good man but it's just not what I'm
trying to feel this morning you want
something else Mighty Mighty Bosstones
well Paul was a vegan now got a new Paul
Paul name oh yeah all skinny and healthy
he grew a beard yeah he's still sitting
sideways but he's sitting oh look I
think he's just selling grills now oh
damn mr. steel your grill oh wait to
Andy to be more thick he probably
stopped drinking all that scissor that
[__] is so much sugar in it yeah dude I
remember going to if in Atlanta if you
go to the coca-cola museum they have all
the difficulty and beverages from
different
trees right so you can taste all the
ones that they have in all the different
countries some countries have different
names and stuff you know but but they'll
have like Coke and like Fanta all the
ones that coke owns so you can go to all
the machines and try all of them yeah
dude you go to the Africa one it is the
sugar East
won't buy far it's like drinking cough
syrup you're like thick bro it's crazy
bro man you go to the Japanese one and
it is like very has very little sugar in
it America's one is like in the middle
but some of the countries man Brazil to
had like the most sugary [__] ever I'm
like oh yeah I mean now I think if I was
a kid or if I'd that's all I knew I
would love it
mmm but sitting sideways Paul what was
good man okay we got a rap battle this
week oh he's back my favorite parts a
alert so too last time we did it we had
we uh what's that and look I will tell
you this dude I your innate it next to
Paul wall a torrential ones [__] yeah
and he was cool and he shook my hand
right after hand a hand and he knows
your hand was touching that day my own
dick bags in the urinal yeah then you
shook his hand
with that day and he shook hit my hand
what a man what a man you think he's
wearing a [__] what a mighty good no
deals dick hands I'm scared of getting
[__] paulie good 19 dude Koba control
bro who has it who you guys have it yet
nope yet when you get tested y'all got
tested no we didn't get tested I want to
get to uh suppose we go to my buddy's
house and get tested today he has tes
hmm so how much it cost though so mine
was $200 was it really hmm what is this
Nick I'm just gonna hope I don't have it
for 200 your odds it's a smart move
you get this rap battle so little brows
ended up winning we had a really close
50-50 vote that was only separated by 35
with wiser hip-hop and big gracias and
little de nada
those are both great but little brows
just dominated again we get so many
submissions now I have to that like the
not as highly produced but they're good
and we should watch them and they're
quicker and then actual contenders the
contenders are [__] sweet let's put
him in here comes young white guy have
the same bloated face apparently he's on
the same medication ah Mon bro don't be
one of the people that's blame and
they're freaking bloated face um thyroid
medicine thyroid medicine doesn't have
frosting on cancellous Brea shows Kay
said his brain hurt my brain was leaking
out of my ear that make sense I woke up
on warning and a couple ideas I had
where all my fellow I'm like this ain't
good I gotta cancel the show see but I
gotta shut it down dude
how could how far it takes to get there
in the traffic I do I've been there dude
I did it with you three times that's
right yep
[Music]
what years ago this years ago they tried
years ago ship out weren't you saying
the year here's an Instagram yeah he's
alive yeah he's alive as he thriving I
didn't look at him no it's like random
[__] that he broke I mean reading it
throwing one in the jaw right there
warming that jaw I'm a big dog this is
him
yep there is Marshall Pope he had a real
Marshall Pope right there yeah other
followers gang [__] he's got a lot of
followers 300 I said he actually
returned this was all happened no pun
intended years ago he returned to the
news and he actually did freestyle if we
want to hear it yeah hell yeah he
redeemed himself
[Laughter]
slammer
booyah what's [__] up wrapping the
right self publishing books invisible
shutters got the whole world [__] Who am
I
damn Derrick Thomas car app a white boy
here's one son three girls what the
struggles are luck cuz love is hard
well I wouldn't be able to do with that
the love from God you're crazy looks
like Derrick Thomas rest in peace yeah
too many kisses Thomas a lot of love
right how the ban was finest years ago
years ago oh I don't know well three
years ago bring up Marshall Faulk gains
weight you think he looks like a thick
Marshall Faulk e yeah I don't know if
there is even a picture here Martha
fault fat yeah get that blue shirt
finding that blue here that blue t-shirt
no no no no no no [__]
go back yeah right there
no no blue shirt thank you sir
years ago bro use I don't be good
everybody gonna think when they get
older huh oh he does look like him
clothes I think it looks more like dirt
Thomas though I don't know bro that's
close overall I think it's really a mix
it's like Derrick Thomas and Marshall
Faulk had a baby he came out thick yeah
he came up thick and uncertain hey you
almost had a mental he this years ago
yeah he weighs like no don't do it
we need Nick to redeem himself with that
eggy song yeah the same moment one day
Nick Chappelle dropped those [__]
flow for us it was Paul Wall wasn't my
flow but you remember it is he's not his
flow yeah white rappers are killing it
over here yeah except this one this was
this came from a Jared who's actually a
girl and she wrote in her email not
white I don't have a penis and I've
never wrapped her made a beat but I have
got a white guy's name so put me in
coach
[Music]
[Applause]
I know if I do it over that rock beat
that EDM that's fine yeah what a tricky
beat is a good effort first female
rapper what do you think at female to
female female a female love her okay
she's not gonna be [__] brows though
this is her first time Brendan everyone
what a kid on a tricycle and think he's
gonna be damn
you know she's this is king of sings
using the big leagues huh
this is the big leagues not yeah you're
right trying to be brows but I bring the
heat yeah there's a good effort
appreciate the effort is a good lady she
was great she was great they've just
become total that's great let's don't
lie to the lady also all right what do
you want man we have to give a room to
grow we have to be supportive
you know I'm supportive that's why I
said she's great there's a great effort
for her first time that's what I think
okay now she's gonna beat little brows
[__] the first black female that's true
dude Jackie Robinson Kingdom she's Bubba
Sparxxx she's Rosa sparks
what do you got Matt dude you know who
turned into throws up parks was [__]
Cam Newton do but when he started
dressing like uh he started dressing
like a woman from the 1930s a [__]
[__] and his play went down
you got his play went down got crazy
there's nobody's giving him a deal right
now
are they well some was gonna pick up
he's been so injured though yeah that's
true huh hell of a player though MVP MVP
in 2015 MVP he couldn't a van dude 2015
he's a [__] following man you know
what's crazy - he got kicked off the
Florida team when they had Tebow that in
Hernandez they had all those ballers he
got kicked off the team for stealing a
laptop no way hmm I do not steal a
laptop in college that's what I want to
know who wasn't stealing what else you
got like a real contender we got two
they're really good no gang gang gang
buzzin like an animal bus and that's a
Buffalo Trace mr. Bratt cane cane no he
gang gang gang no we can gang gang
buzzing uh perpetual talk form in the
lecture was Brenda no accessible feel a
sexual plane what the money not a nose
never more cat tween whooping boss yeah
like a matador oh that's the culture
corner got forest back chinny-chin-chin
your psycho to not to show girls like oh
do you know but I never say never do
anything for him bars but now back you
support chores it's not money that's
really hard
always red-handed in the honey jar got
the block talking gang share don't care
hit the bank [__] shining up in this
[__] wow that was fun that's fun yeah
it's hard to hear this it's hard to hear
a lot of what he's saying why is that uh
I don't know is he loud enough in there
I think he's just the way he's sent it
in or something yeah it's just they're
not all the best produced like producers
I mean yeah they're just not mixes Raj
and he's not producing that thing but I
mean for doing himself like that was
pretty it was a huge video and yeah it
was good my like the birdieing go yeah
that's real that was real quality put it
he added in a lot of photos and stuff
man he did a really good job man it was
fun yeah what's fun this one is also
incredibly fun this is from this is
called tiger sting by buck Jeffery and
little streaks Oh buck Jeffery a little
Street both bought Jeffrey and little
streaks are played by evan Davis that
your as your [__] underwear company
financially with televisions
but Jeffrey don't bad will Chunkin be to
work shot a boy he never had this shop
this deal all the paint go hard like
DeRose the [__] you get all zeros money
the banks I just see touchdowns I don't
quit
all go hard like a bone in the paint
touching on bust down masturbate back to
my holes 15 in the endzone sure stay
tucked in all day I win back scratch
margarine high socks no hair my space
garden shrieks okay yeah we've gone too
far yeah I feel like yeah white rappers
get weird on us dude that [__] went
[__] deep to be [__] little brows
I think we got to open up to all
ethnicities I don't know why boys get
real weird little brows speaking I've
actually sent in an updated version oh
one new positivity I hid it son Biddy
mm-hmm Wow spice it up premiering here
and has never been seen before I [__]
love this dude dude he's a great blog
how does like the egg stir okay last one
and then I am done they got me beating
on my chest fee fie foe fum they
sleeping on me like the slept Kingdom I
was waiting on a banger but I didn't
hear one except lazy girl sound an
outdated a bunch of guys on the couch
saying Flo new faces
don't say my [__] is wack cuz you sound
crazy I got the beat doin flips like
Chappelle lazy Luke oh but at the same
time I drop the heaters you boys sound
like wall-e from Leave It to Beaver gee
willikers man I wouldn't like me either
they trying to pick apart ground like a
parrot wheeze on the [__] zone now
why'd you get me started trying to beat
me they don't have to try a little bit
harder here in the murderer when I'm in
the park a lot better like harder forest
between songs if I really wanna roast a
wall I could
but I would read between this to a cop
yeah yeah I can't see the haters from
the top it's picking kind of cringy
y'all should stop I just felt the
competition drop but I would read it
through this tool pop it sticking kind
of cringy y'all should stop I just hope
the competition he is like Brendan's
hair on Theo horses in the back shoutout
to the Paiste bros Derek sent away for
way too many episodes find out if his
girl is okay and then let us know don't
shop with cat all wrong so many dogs
coming off too strong Jenn stage it and
really last that long just bought a
bunch of alcohol and then went home
y'all need a tiger King type a throne
that I can sit on so where's my crown
let me keep that king of sting low growl
King I can't see the haters from the
toss okay these girls and the cringy
y'all should stop get why
[Music]
the competition peaker libre
professional and hints so music he got
the neighborhood to be in this video at
t fern three gay yeah that's a pro son
buzz pro game son is that [__] god
sham god is that it's Delonte West yeah
I found on the street
oh man little browse man there's so hard
in the paint
yeah a real pro Wow he said that's his
last one huh I don't think anybody's
ever gonna beat him so I don't know what
we do I think we opened up to all
ethnicities do we change the job I was
gonna say overall talent show or singing
get some instruments yeah we change them
in I don't up in this [__] you can rap
sing whatever you want no one's gonna
beat little brows it's not having we
think you're never American my dolls
just give me cramps some of his [__]
Bulls but no laughs you know he said he
said Chen's just an alcohol talked about
her tits get hammered drinking a lot of
sake was like her tits are nice yeah I
mean the cameras shut off and then said
he was married actor he said he's been
in an arranged marriage news does broke
wasted our goddamn money and time yeah
cuz hundred seventy dollars our poor oh
yeah our poor [__] friend with the
fat tissue she was looking for love you
son of a [__] you honeydicked that poor
girl no she has a name what was it Oh
Harley they call it Carl
Carly yes Carly I called her hot Carl
Carlito at the kita Carl she was great
she was awesome man
well yeah maybe she's sending a video
give us an update on your love life yeah
and if we ever said in a video maybe
yeah yes he's doing he's an updating out
datings been during the quarantine
seeing anyone or if she's been a lot of
guys hit her up did she want any dates
from people that hit her up from this
love to know more about that mean if you
sick stay at home if you sick come on
over do you want to pick a genre music
country no I I think all the ich you it
can be anything I think we open up the
floodgates man yeah yeah I'm open to
whatever here's a lady right here that
has an issue gang [__] hi guys my name
is Kelly and I'm a ninth grade English
teacher in Las Vegas in Marvis my school
transitioned into online distance
learning which means I didn't get a
chance to prank my archnemesis the 9th
grade history teacher hoping you guys
can help me out with that today while
also uplifting my students spirits
Brendan I need you to take it easy on
the f-bombs
here we go told Aristotle once said that
poetry is finer and more philosophical
than history for poetry expresses the
universal history only the particular
here's the debate English teachers
versus history teachers choose wisely
again gain those buzz Gaylords Bob I
said Brendan yeah my baton sorry I won't
[__] this up what I would do well dude
first of all English teachers all day
history teachers talking that [__]
man just spread them lies dude how about
how about you juice on some real facts
like how about George Washington wooden
teeth I say this you mean teeth from the
slaves those teeth weren't wood and you
think cut down no [__] apple tree
well it's all a bunch of lies man you
think he's so de slaves tooth into its
mouth
that's more realistic than sewing wood
into his [__] mouth does it make
think about it easier to do something
right now yeah think about
yes bro what I'm saying is dude you can
easily put a piece of wood in your mouth
look at a toothpick you're not gonna
stay there huh it's not gonna shape it
you believe that [__] the wood would get
soggy huh no put someone else's tooth in
your mouth bro that's more realistic
than wood look at this I don't I don't
know if I'm the only one who has the the
weird recollection of being taught that
George Washington had wooden teeth
anyway no his dentures were made of
teeth from his slaves yep from oat milk
40 okay 40 over countrymen mrs. fields
40 and was my history teacher
spin that [__] over Miriam and
Webster dog from a real history book
those books are fake oh my god a George
Washington and slave teeth according
George Washington's ledger on May 8th
1740 page six panelists who shillings
two Negroes 490 that of dr. Lemoine so
he was a middle man dude so he was
running teeth do you run an enamel you
had a hole teeth [__] scheme Doug yes
did you know this that a lot of speaking
of grills um slave owners would get if
they like their slaves they would get
gold put into their mouths into the
slaves mouse to show off their wealth Oh
dance if I can look I came from look I'm
a dog little Terry right here and Terry
what flex that gold yeah seven crazy
damn damn little lamps got one go Lance
your stop his goddamn game up yeah yeah
Tyrone got all gold fronts but Lance was
also black I think it is a it's can be a
black name yeah yeah Lance now is you'd
have a black Lance 20 years ago nope
well 20 years ago I don't think so you
think
pinky had a homeboy Lance Oh Lance
there's a famous the lyric was just my
home book kickin it with my homeboy
Lance who said that biggie
oh wow hmm what would the fan say 60
60% said history teachers history is
more fun for sure you just said no no it
was funner but I like English teachers I
like history cuz then pictures of
cannons in the book what it's more fun
all right we got one quick debate club
to close it out quit keeping with school
theme yeah what's up Ted it's up Brandon
Brendan you look like an umpire at an
adult softball league game and faeo I
saw you with Amsterdam walking on the
side of the street we cross paths
I said gang gang you said what's up so I
just want to say thanks for that I don't
know if you remembered we spoken
Instagram but anyways you guys remember
that he's asking you dude what did he
ask me do you remember do you remember
talked to him on Instagram I don't know
I thought he said ice told me what's out
of the street he said that too but then
he said like you can't even talk to you
about an Instagram
oh no the man that I saw was all working
for posts mates I think his name was
William that might be him no this man
was blond-headed unless he shaved his
head it couldn't man come on shoot yes I
do remember brother when you were in
school did you one strap the backpack or
did you to strap it
Brendan I know you have more experience
in this cuz Theo you were homeschooled
for your old life but you know anyway
our backpacks short bus brother good to
see you again dude
I do want to say that and I do remember
this beautiful guy dude
and he wrote this little thick piece
laying slim fat inside the road in
Amsterdam
yeah I'm slinging out those slim slows
and and slippery Joe's oh one one or two
in college I went to in high school I
went one
cool let me think about that college you
went to in college the books were
[__] heavy dude
books forever yeah you couldn't go ten
to one yeah one in high school was a
little bit more like hey I'm gonna kill
myself what look at me you know kind of
do the depression like oh man
oh not my no no one stepped in high
school man I'm down to do something yeah
to meant you were a door trying to get
some stats you know two in high school
yeah was dorky two in high school was
dorky doing College made sense though
the books are so heavy but then they
always had like we had this the biggest
guy like guy at our school that's got TJ
Moen he used to wear two straps and he
was like a big tough do till he got to
do whatever I think also depending on
who you were true you know but he also
had no books in his book bag either
which was also crazy all that I did I
remember opened his book and I wanted to
have like seven pencils did you ever
wear overalls
cuz if you left one of those you leave
one off like you're criss cross if you
stopped in the middle of gangster that's
gay bro one overall one overall yeah and
then the girls are doing that tips oh
that's sexy bro yeah that's sexy
if I see a girl in overalls dude game on
we get in under all's that's sex bro
what would the fans say eighty percent
said to strap it yeah yeah too small I
think it's definitely too sure I got
that JanSport
or that North Face got to do two straps
done it's all about business these days
do did you ever have where your book bag
distract him with running you had to
[__] sew it back up and it was
plastic and that [__] would get all
ready and then get it tie it [__]
together what's the hot thing on the
streets now with backpacks or JanSport
still in I think it's just no education
I think yeah you see a lot of kids can't
even learn early kids just take their
tablets everywhere now yeah they used to
make us buy the we remember the whole
[__] Ponzi scheme those math teachers
with the ti-83 the Texas Instrument when
those things came out they blew regular
calculators out
what do you play video games on it yeah
well it what do you that was algebra
first of all you're talking about and
you download games on the ti-83 really
yep that's why everyone's all crunk
about them oh I never did that I
remember the up that with like the
old-school calculation you could write
something and turn backwards spell
boobies no he was eight zero zero eight
one three five
I know seals boobies six nine two two
two five one times eight spells boobless
yeah you guys are doing real well I
think we open up the the rap battle I
think we open up like American I'll on
this [__] whatever town you die what do
you think Kat what do you think
Chappelle on the battle what do we do oh
yeah I totally respect your opinion
there Brendon what do you what do you
think we do guys talent browsers blue
ruin all the water so the submissions
are sending documentaries and [__]
yeah that one guy definitely and one was
a cry for help even I think yeah I think
one was Tommy Hilfiger's son I don't
know what's not in this absolu play one
of a backwards just start crying you
know you can hear doves cry what do you
think what do you think we do um I don't
know cuz how would you go and show like
lowbrow against someone whose town is
like dance how do you compare that
American Idol style we take a vote in
here don't miss - yes six people in
denim style yeah it was good
wait keep little brows in it no he's
fine he won he won it's not yeah we got
to get him something huh yeah
order the belt belt or trophy yeah let's
do my belt
singing the sting rap belt yeah order
from the same guys you guys ordered the
first spider in the cage Jamie about
that sack - one no hater the second was
good it came a year late but it was good
oh my bad yeah well dude it takes a
while to make [__] gold okay I
respect that route though gold actually
takes a long time to make thousands of
years um the second one is very nice the
first one wasn't bad people stole but
people would steal parts of it and [__]
but the second yeah man I have two of a
man well let's give them one some other
guys a young up-and-comer has one I
can't run that guy we'll get him up like
a rap battle belt nice Christopher
that's a little browser name on there oh
yeah [__] in on the on the outside of
the Belkin of to browse on it put his
picture up right on the wall right yeah
we should get him up here bro their Hall
of Fame wall yep yeah well enough to
come to some to all or do we could just
go to a new genre of music is that what
we do well new is honorin you're not
gonna get too many submissions if we
just do country well we hold on I don't
think it's just been a white rappers
been every rapper but it was that's just
kind of the joke when we started that
has been predominantly who sent him in
but we we had that one guy who said the
n-word was he white no yeah do you
something else we had a black girl today
yes fair we're inclusive okay yeah yeah
I feel like we're inclusive but I feel
like we just don't we didn't get any
submissions that's what I feel like I
feel like we didn't get a lot of
submissions either I didn't do the
selections I didn't see that what the
who you know what though chin should
make a song and the people have to beat
that I think you should have categories
so look all rappers than any singers and
then also like battle the bands that'd
be cool too then what about break
dancers that too watching somebody
danced you don't think it has anything
to do with what we're doing here I'm not
watching some men dance dude there's
female break dancers that's true but
they are strong they'll have a buzz cut
yeah we all have buss cuts on their uh
on their DNA as well that make them love
women usually
I just think we open it up see what
everything we get what just to
everything so just one like one winner
for everything makes it well that's the
only thing I'm like do it because if we
open it up I think we open it up but do
we open it up like and say okay submit
now let's go to this category or do we
open it up just because little browsers
were doing wrapping mm-hmm you know so
what would the category be singing yeah
singers so just two singers from yeah
that'd be cool I know there's a ton of
people that love to sing so yeah I would
say there's a couple of singing is
usually something you do before you
become a [__] hit man if it doesn't
work out on the girls submit yeah that's
what they're gonna do fans of the show
there's gonna forcing the sing so are we
talking like acapella
are we talking like country not amazing
anything yeah well because we just did
rap we can do country okay singing I
just just straight up singing okay and
put your genre if we get enough for
specific we'll mix it up week to week if
not we'll put them all together do it in
the shower the shower hitters and Poetry
Slam if you want to do poetry as well
like what's her name what's her name is
Miss Pat know the teacher her name was
Kelly it was like Kelly said Wow
Oh a tree is more important yeah we ever
vote on this because I liked history
because of the cannons and I kissed
because of the war we should do we
should be able to do a Civil War
Reenactment on the playground every year
oh that's cool it's pretty cool during
Black History Month was it the entire
month that became the Black History we
just studied Malcolm X well sometimes
you got to uh we had what did we do we
had like we had a cannon we had archery
somebody got to be Native American they
would always try to like package it up
with some other she does easier on
Thanksgiving mm-hmm but it was pretty
fun you could make you study Geronimo
and [__] we got to eat like stuff that
they had in the Civil War Civil War food
that's nice there's pretty queef jerky
and [__] uh yeah or more like biscuits a
lot of biscuits into somebody will play
the whole one it was pretty fun dude
it's a good time to like kind of if you
were flirting with chicks or whatever is
a good time I'm trying for work you were
out of class you were in class you were
out on the place the best and somebody
flew a kite into the power lines and
[__] electrocuted themselves one year
we shut it down people were pissed dude
it was the first time the north and
south are on the same side us against
this one [__] kid William bad news
for will man oh he was a piece of [__]
dude he was always uh what great is this
seventh grade fifth yeah god it was fun
dude
[Music]
that's pretty good
your the muskets it was good huh yeah we
had mustard we had a man that would come
in that had real weaponry and he got to
hold that we got to hold the fake ones
damn he just went all out but it was fun
yeah pretty fun
oh look at this which is better corn the
band or corn the [__] vegetable
Oh 62% the real corn r.i.p brian welts
dude can you play us out some corn Nick
freak on a leash or you could just put
wind blow your core
what's your favorite corn song Chappelle
um she softer early album like this
peachy would we know oh and ball tongs
really good
[Music]
oh yeah
this I remember my brother started
listening to this when we started to
stop being friends
[Laughter]
they were good huh okay
Wynonna add a big brown beaver eye and
she showed us all her friends or that
song chin does this little more
underground highway it's their second
album give me more more one of their
hits now yeah here's what I got the life
or something yeah play something yeah
get that hit out Oh with the cartoon
beloved my brother I love this man
something like Donnelly yes mm-hmm
I don't know how white people dance to
this I have I worked security for them
oh you do
relief for them and then Hilary Duff I
could see that bird tough enough to work
yeah can't get enough of that
yeah baby hey what's the video what they
have with the bullet this is it with the
bullet no the books gone through the
glass
it starts in cartoon and it turns real
what a great video man this is the kind
of music angry white dudes make chili to
this music
like a nice French there from tali-rite
yeah Bakersfield yeah
are they mad yeah have you done that
club in Bakersfield yeah
there's no bullet Brendan that's my
favorite
it's a god bus lamp Oh literally a lamps
busted so I don't still see all we
haven't made the bus lamp here your show
right man boom boom boom boom
PG baby praise God see where's the skirt
you
what a great [__] look at them just
rocking out dude
what's the loop suitors home for then
even in this Jonathan day hotties about
us biscuit fan I like limbus you know
give me some limp biscuit break stuff
you know I was listening to on my bike
ride this morning I just do I do a
playlist of one band solace and the
whole band on the ride all their topic
what is it
I listen to Rage Against the Machine
yeah that shouldn't make you wanna start
a revolution
dude what about Ray Charles Against the
Machine have you seen that I don't think
he's seen it either
oh no I'm saying of John Henry the
steel-driving man if you ever remember
that I love that guy it's a heart
exploding he's he's sober no wonder that
Ray Charles John Goffe thing with
limpiar fred durst yeah he's sober a lot
of those guys are now they went wild
yeah they're all like a lot of them were
sober the Red Nosed is that they're all
into Jesus now - that's a bummer
Dahmer do you want to go to hell it's a
bummer but you don't it's not so just a
choices thing so coming together those
marry him and Method Man yeah he'd like
remember that after that everybody that
had a red hat on it was just Fred Durst
that was like the total it was uh it
became the Halloween costume for dudes
it didn't want to walk shirt on and a
red you know he's directed movies really
anything no he did one what ice cube in
it yeah what did he do we look on his
IMDB do you mind yeah he's directed some
movies because I know Rob Zombie does
the scary movies yeah yeah I try to get
me to do my comedy special fred durst Oh
Rob Zombie I'm Bobby
they call him Bobby you call him Bobby
now yeah I'm like you can't B Bobby
zombie dude that's Rob Robert zombie huh
yeah and the same flow
yeah Rob Zombie and you direct this
goddamn comedy special she's got nothing
else to do oh he does great
holy didn't do it the education of
Charlie look at this [__] that looks
horrible kid is horrible off you oh dude
don't know Heisenberg no he's great
you think I like him you didn't see him
in uh in the the Facebook one social
networks cuz their network is great yeah
that's the one I saw that I didn't
realize he direct longshot he's fine
biscuit look at him he directed this the
limp biscuit thing who he directed poem
mud too blurry behind blue eyes did he
really
yeah who is he Oh Fred you're
something's wrong B oh I'm doing Rob
Zombie zombi to hit you with some real
horror movies though his shits to do
gory from me though I like scary I don't
like gory yeah I like scary to do we
shall watch a scary movie sometime not
just us you free I guess I want to come
over and watch a scary movie with you
dude
you and your plant I have three plants
and one of them is black it's cuz I
didn't water it but I still diversity
directed Tom Pappas yeah
I'm Papa's hilarious make you nice
[__] sourdough loaf to does he make
good bread yeah that's what he does he
has a show making bread he does grateful
bread damn well I made up the grateful
bread thing I don't know if you care for
bread as a company though actually I
think that does mean that's also merch I
so um oh you're coming out with a new
bread company now yeah I'm getting baked
giving baked Oh getting a job you really
try and get Rob Zombie
director/screenwriter
that's all you wanted to do it
[Laughter]
that's right yeah what was this famous
one Oh Devil's Rejects that uh yeah did
you get there's nothing to do it's like
you go to the gas station and you just
you know you stop it placed and just
walk around people are in the
supermarket there's nothing to do have a
mask on because all these [__] judge
you if not I just sit and spew off facts
dude in the mask I don't they do
anything no no all they do is show you
if [__] breath oh yeah my brother's bad
ah - ha ha I pull my own doubts just my
[__] my [__] big old nose hanging
up the top sucking up all that air but
you're supposed to cover your nose and
mouth yeah I know I don't I'm a rebel
dude I'm a rebel Donny name the movie uh
I'm a rebel down I'm a rebel Donny a hot
uh I know what it is young trouble for
Johnny Roscoe no pee-wee Herman's big
adventure oh yeah yeah I went on the day
trying to play him there I'm trying to
get who'd you go on a date with big
Marge now I'm trying to get from pee-wee
Herman direct my next special
yes rates pretty low bro and that outfit
he'll definitely direct it ok he'll
direct it right onto your back
you try go on a date with Large Marge
dude with pee-wee's girlfriend in that
oh really the one who made the [__]
uh the egg egg salad sandwich those
trippin on us trippin on her face you
never seen pee-wee's big adventure here
you go right there
Elizabeth daily that's not her daddy I'm
a rebel daddy
yeah he's the original big boys bike
club because his bike got stolen this
was cause the whole moon this [__] you
can barely contain it dude you know why
it takes so long hit those that's actual
Jocko sweat you like a [__] American
you drink that [__] he makes for one
batch one batch just for real I hear an
eagle in it safe
all right all right Brennan and Theo
fighter and wait I gotta go in and go
hard in the paint I do not think I am in
flows like rifle coffee I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this and my concerts flow
is contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
okay like I'm fresh off Quito see a red
like Andrew Santino right every song is
like the great Bambino gonna take the
case oh and a case Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine matches in
his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
try to couldn't beat em quit playin like
Nintendo DS you don't want to smoke like
Joey Diaz meaning y'all edible just got
my eyebrows threaded and I'm feeling
incredible bread and Sun him me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up stinky
and the sting bee sting Rat King
as a sting King a nasty kind of beez in
the trap gotta cheese on a string over
here
and the sting king and the stinking in
the sting bee sting Rat King
and a sting sting cheese on the stream
spinning and do fighter in Creole
shoutout New Orleans and shout-out to Co
Colorado more specifically Boulder
Brendan came in with a chip on his
shoulder but is still gold and yet it
still fire refute all like King Aniston
you're a liar Brenda's got like a
thousand different hustles one of them's
at Nordstrom rector went I yours black
rifle coffee we hear you loud and clear
your son on the email like please get me
out of here is way too loud in here
watching the Irishman eating pizza
drinking half a beer now on the Theo von
looking like the tub adieu the Tresor
Rita songs smoking cigarettes with a
snapback on that's a hit the [__] intern
snapchat on it's all go we still mess
with you 18:11 Pico Boulevard go get the
head Deborah can cat y'all doing great
Thursday upload not a minute late y'all
wanted to rap a head a demonstrate brand
new studio y'all feelin great putting
Chris Delano in this place now let's go
and get you nerd
[Music]
and the sting came and the sting bee
sting cracking
and a stinking and the sting
the truck got the cheese on a string
ducky listing King in the state king is
a sting bee sting Rat King
as a sting I can't understand gonna
freeze in the traffic got a cheese on a
string
[Music]